in 2022 nearly half of Americans
expected a civil war in the next few
years one in five now believes political
violence is Justified and it's not just
the us but around the world people
increasingly see themselves as part of
opposing teams there are many different
reasons for this but one gets blamed a
lot social media social media divides us
makes us more extreme and less
empathetic it R Us up or sucks us into
Doom scrolling making us stressed and
depressed it feels like we need to touch
grass and escape to the real world new
research shows that we might have
largely misinterpreted why this is the
case it turns out that the social media
internet May uniquely undermine the way
our brains work but not in the way you
think the myth of the filter bubble
you've probably heard about online
filter bubbles algorithms give you
exactly what you want or what they think
you want you only see information that
shows you opinions that agree with yours
while dissenting opinions or information
are filtered out since you only see
content close to your world view more
extreme and toxic opinions suddenly seem
less extreme you're trapped in a
radicalizing filter bubble and your view
of the world becomes narrower and more
extreme but is that true extreme filter
bubbles seem to be rather rare studies
that investigated what people actually
look at online or are shown by search
engines found little evidence that
you're ideologically isolated it's the
exact opposite online you are constantly
confronted with opinions and worldviews
that are not your own it turns out that
the place where you are the most
ideologically isolated is your real life
in the real world with real people your
real world interactions with your
friends family colleagues and neighbors
are much less diverse than your online
bubble the filter bubble exists in your
real life not online okay wait online
filter bubbles have been the prevailing
explanation
as to why we've all started hating each
other more over the last two decades if
that's not the case shouldn't the
internet open our minds and make us more
empathetic with each other unfortunately
your brain is
stupid your brain is stupid human brains
didn't evolve to understand the true
nature of reality but to navigate and
maintain social
structures our ancestors desperately
needed each other to survive so our
brains had to make sure we cooperate it
that's why social isolation or exclusion
feels so horrible because it was
actually life-threatening a tribe that
worked together survived a divided tribe
died the way communities worked for
thousands of years is that sure you may
have disliked a neighbor but because you
lived close to each other you also
rooted for the same sports club or saw
them at church you both thought that the
people from the other Village were
idiots being physically close made you
familiar and created similarities that
bridge the gap of different World Views
so you didn't murder each other and your
world viw was probably not that
different in the first place because it
was formed by the same local culture
when our brains evolved this was enough
whoever was around was similar to us we
liked what was similar to us this kept
us aligned enough to work together
despite our differences as Humanity
moved on from small tribes to towns and
cities from chiefdoms to kingdoms to
Nations our brain and our communities
had to adapt to more diverse sets of
neighbors we began to meet on the Town
Square or in universities where we
argued and screamed at each other but in
the grand scheme of things communities
were still relatively isolated we were
still pretty similar and aligned with
the people around us conflict and
disagreement are not a bad thing per se
tension over how we should live can
create new and wonderful things our
values norms and taboos are always
evolving and whatever we think is normal
today will not be normal in the future
but we also need social glue to hold our
societies together because our brains
don't care about the meta level of
humanity but about being safe in a tribe
until about 20 years ago we did
something truly new that hit our brains
like a fright train the social media
internet the digital Town Square don't
you dare disagree with me social sorting
in a nutshell our brains are not able to
process the amount of disagreement we
encounter on the social internet the
very mechanisms that made it possible
for our ancestors to work together in
the first place are derailed in ways we
were not prepared for whether you want
it to or not your brain sorts people by
World Views and opinions into teams this
is not simply tribalism it goes further
researchers have called this process
social sorting on the digital Town
Square you encounter people that Express
opinions or share information that clash
with your world viw but unlike your
neighbor they don't root for your local
sports club you're missing the local
social glue your brain needs to align
with them for your brain the
disagreement between yourself and them
becomes a central part of their identity
and this makes it less likely that you
will seriously consider their position
or opinion in the future if you hear bad
things about them your brain is much
more likely to believe it uncritically
on the flip side there are people who
share your worldview and are maybe even
more similar to you than many people in
your real life life which makes your
brain like them a lot and kind of hyper
align with them people who think like
you are probably good people because
you're a good person and whatever social
group you belong to is good so your
brain is more likely to believe their
opinions if you hear bad things about
them your brain is much more likely to
dismiss it
uncritically the engagement driven
social internet makes it worse because
it wants to keep you online as long as
possible and the most engaging emotion
is unfortunately anger
the more Angry you get the more likely
you are to share and engage and this
leads to social media amplifying the
most extreme and controversial opinions
it optimizes not only to show us
disagreement but the worst disagreement
possible and because your stupid brain
is sorting people into teams whatever
the worst opinions are it assigns the
same opinions to everybody on the other
team what's striking and new about
online polarization is that all the
aspects of Our Lives that make us
individuals our lifestyle choic The
Comedians or shows we watch our religion
sense of fashion and so on are condensed
making it seem that their parts of
opposing and mutually exclusive
identities this simplifies and distorts
disagreements about how we should run
Society so much that it often seems as
if the people on the other team are
actively willfully making the world
worse that they're almost evil Beyond
convincing with rationality facts or
civil discussion while you are of course
on the correct team it may be be hard to
process that you may seem like that to
people on the other team on a societal
level this is dissolving the social glue
that's the foundation of our democracies
if we think our neighbors are evil how
can we live together this is especially
bad in the US where the two party system
makes it extra easy to think of people
in terms of teams negative opinion about
the other party has reached record
highs okay is there something we can
learn from this is there something we
can do something more positive opinion
part in the end it's important to be
aware of what social media does to your
brain it's easier to change yourself
than to change the world so you can
self-examine why you believe the things
you believe and whether you dismiss or
believe information based on who the
person is who is stating that
information the internet comes with a
lot of ups and downs and just like we
had to adapt from living in small tribes
to living in cities we need to adapt to
the information age where we have access
to billions of people evolution is too
slow so we need to find models that work
with what our brains are able to
tolerate one model that seemed to work
well was the pre-social media internet
old people might remember bulletin
boards forums blogs the main difference
to today was twof fault for one there
were no algorithms fighting to keep you
online at any cost at some point you
were done with the internet for the day
as mind-blowing as this may sound but
more importantly the old internet was
very fractured split into thousands of
different communities like small
villages gathering around shared beliefs
and interests these Villages were
separated from each other by digital
rivers or
mountains these communities worked
because they mirrored real life much
more than social media each Village had
its own culture and set of rules maybe
one Community was into rough humor and
soft moderation another had strict rules
and banned easily if you didn't play by
The Village rules you'd be banned or you
could just go and move to another
Village that suited you better so
instead of all of us gathering in one
place overwhelming our brains at a Town
Square that in the end just leads us to
going insane one solution to achieve
less social sorting may be extremely
simple go back to smaller online
communities because what our stupid
brains don't realize is that we are
actually all on the same team Humanity
on a wet Rock speeding through space in
a universe that doesn't think about us
we are all in this together but until
our brains adjust to being able to deal
with that we might be better off being a
tiny bit
separated one of the worst things about
the media we consume is that most news
organizations tend to cat to one team
making you feel you're on the correct
side ground news the sponsor of this
video is trying to make these biases
more transparent by giving you tools
that help you think critically about the
information you consume a mission we
wholeheartedly support ground news
gathers related articles from around the
world in one place so you can compare
how different outlets and sides cover
them they provide context about the
source of the information if they have a
political bias how reliable their
reporting is and who owns them this
makes the news less stressful and makes
you understand the world much better if
you want to check them out go to ground.
news/ Nutshell if you sign up through
this link you'll get 30% of their
unlimited access plan a subscription
supports KAG and ground news so they can
continue to build more media literacy
tools our favorite tool has a personal
background in 2018 kazak founder Philip
who wrote this video was going through
chemotherapy and was intensely Bor so he
ended up reading all the big German
newspapers even the ones he hated front
to back every single day aside from the
obvious biases what was the most
shocking were the stories each side did
not talk about both sides IGN ignored
things that are inconvenient to their
World Views the ground news blind spot
feed highlights this exact thing showing
you news stories that are heavily
covered by one side of the political
spectrum and ignored by the other so
check them out at ground. news/ nutshell
to make sure you're seeing the full
[Music]
picture